blog mans numero 6 mi siedo per terra
per dirvi che finalmente sono tornato in
possesso del calendario dell'avvento che
ha fatto tutta la mia famiglia insieme
collaborazione con di cellule che questo
quarto sold out tra parentesi continuate
a scriverci dover raro trovarlo
contattate da me dicevo perché
gestiscono loro non prendiamo nemmeno
royalties è una cosa che abbiamo fatto
per promuoverlo e che poi in realtà è un
po esplosa
non posso dirlo questa è la cosa triste
perché mia madre e mia zia e lo hanno
dato a mia nonna regalandogli ero così è
buffo qui adesso mia nonna non vuole che
minimamente tenda toccato a vento ci
stanno con un sacco di roma t.ni
immaginerò così con la lista l'asiatico
lo guardo immagino che cosa ci possa
essere dentro tipo qua qua c'è qualcosa
di grosso oppure no
in avanti per aver ce ne faremo una
ragione la barba da giorni cantine
adesso non so a chi dice di non mente
quando si fanno barba il terrore di
scoprire cosa c'è sotto i 27 mariti e
burro e che s'è magnato si vedono che
modo che cambia la faccia se non ho mai
creduto di passarlo thaci ha già ha già
saba mentre mannini mentre descrivendo
forò rajasthan casa ha fatto non vi
dimenticate di commentare digitando 1
per votare la mia espulsione dalla casa
ma il cinema verità sempre con diversi
tipi lette sa far sì che bene anche
banco
immagino un tagliere mentre tu stai
aspettando il prison quanto perché io ho
bisogno di affetto e quindi più siete
qui larghi con le persone mamma mia
ragazza senza turisti che ho non nessun
altro permettere al bisogno di un nuovo
faccia a faccia ciao giovani meno ma una
brutta notizia ma i nostri spettatori
stanzialmente ci passiamo noi il nostro
caro alessandro che ci montevideo
intasiamo notevolmente le memorie dei
nostri computer che sono arrivate al
limite il blog ma non finisce qui questa
è l'ultima puntata dell'uomo si sentono
più bella della mia vita enrico cosa è
certa la paghi due
amore non te l'hanno data la buona
notizia che ne andiamo ancora qui se
l'ha preso bene della vita dai soci
latenza rapporto quindi mi vado a
comprare cappotto voi che fate mi faccio
vedere le gioie di romanista della roma
davvero gremita e con milano se vedemo
dopo aver portato la sedia prezzo ecco
chi era un gesto di ribellione però si
può anche tornavo dire le ragazze
hashtag funky blues mentre tutti con cui
busquets e allora vi porto verso rione
monti dove ho abitato a e facciamo un
calcolo delle finanze quanto abbiamo
tutti certo sono 70 centesimi a godere
la vita ci aspetta
diciamo una lira facciamo un caffè da
turista possiamo ancora piano piano
eccoci siamo nel cuore di rione monti
dove gabriel ha abitato cosa pensi sia
rimasto qualche amico tuo che si possa
da una mano tiene di amici che sono
state due settimane di amicizia pura
realtà prende un caffè per 4 persone
[Musica]
utile insomma chi so bene sto caffè
signora al tavolo si estinguono gli
uomini e di volare d'olio mi trovo a
casa da solo adesso con il cane e non so
se li vedete i miei gatti che sono gli
unici esseri viventi che ancora mi
vogliono bene io e ho aiutato di lavoro
e quei ragazzi e loro ne hanno voltato
le spalle se ne sono andati e questo è
l'ultimo blog ma forse è meglio così
forse è meglio così forse giusto io stia
da sud e che passi questo natale come me
comico questa casa è troppo grande non è
vero costituto l'altro poi manda per me
scrivere da solo anzi comunque dicevo
questa casa è troppo grande per me sarà
veramente un anno solitario chissà come
staranno sicuramente staranno molto
meglio adesso che si sono liberati di
volfango conosce qualcuno mi ha scritto
ho sentito un picco sarà un duro
messaggio naturalmente dirà ma ne
rimarrà solo ragazzi un buon natale e
prog massa finisce qui
cosa che però mi fai fare un giro da
solista ma poi comprare una cartolina
noi siamo una setta per una cartolina a
saperla la bocca da veritas i ragazzi
non ci abbiamo una lira dobbiamo
inventarci qualcosa di carino a lavorare
per convenienza
un amico che lavora al thotel siamo
rimasti siamo fratelli
dopo una cazzata è il suo giorno libero
mi sto sentendo in colpa anche solo per
pensarlo i rom
sapete che tutto sommato il silenzio
d'ordine perché pian piano sto mettendo
tutto quanto a posto mi giro e le robe
che lascia in modo rimangono in quel
modo cioè una cosa che mi mancava della
mia solitudine nel riuscire a bastarmi
queen dire che forse non tutti i mali
vengono per nuocere arti base meglio
così primo ha avuto un crollo ma meglio
così raga avendo così si ci posso fare
il cazzo mi pare terribile disastro ma
certa fortuna ma non so abbiamo fatto
noi abbiamo fatto una cazzata ma chiede
che abbiamo esagerato ci abbiamo mai
esagerato
quello che ho fatto ma siamo vedete
derby mi guarda e pensa già al valore
cosa ti prego ne ho bisogno
a me lo metto il cappello che la scena
in qualche posto veramente fantastico
binello relax
una musica di sottofondo che alessandro
mi ha messo in post produzione di
mettere un filtro così opulento cristo
mi sento vivo adesso sì che inizia della
fame e niente gabriele scappato col
malloppo certo che potevate parla la
borsa in due la mia qualcuno che niente
stava ritornando a casa perché stiamo
facendo la fame e oppure scordato dalla
serie couple d'america dobbiamo entrare
in casa senza far accorgere guglielmo
sindacati e l'altra e non ci penso io
che sono
[Musica]
ma è una casa con harry e marco forse
devo fare un po più forte già sentito
decide di aiutare senza centravanti
fa freddo
natalia valli stiamo facendo la fame
vero fan culo
bush valentino è occupato nella home e
sa che non hai capito bene perché non mi
fa temere qualcuno però c'è anche io
dentro anche io dentro dove sono gli
altri gabriele scappavo ha scippato una
fan la linea la linea e dove andarsi a
comprare un cappotto ed è sparita ok ora
poi smette di parlare fila lavinia
adesso poi il mio aiuto dove sei bene
torna a casa con le tue forze non
m'interessa si strisce rai
per quanto riguarda voi invece
continuate a chiamarmi si sergente
istruttore capito no no no no no tu mi
chiamerà i my lord invece per voi
rimarrò sempre il vostro caro gu ci
vediamo al domani con un altro blog alle
14 ciao